[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue nous retrouvons autour de deux
invités qui ont bravé les intempéries
pour rejoindre bonsoir que et morin vous
êtes politologue associé à la fondation
jean jaurès
votre dernier livre le populisme au
secours de la démocratie avec un point
d'interrogation quand même a été publié
chez gallimard ya quelques jours dans la
collection le débat et puis j'ajoute que
vous avez été membre du cabinet de deux
premiers ministres socialistes jean marc
ayrault et manuel valls
vous étiez en charge de l'opinion
publique bonsoir gabriel cluzel vous
êtes journaliste rédactrice en chef du
site boulevard voltaire est votre
dernier livre enracinée nous sommes tous
d héritier a été publiée aux éditions
artège vous propose de commencer cette
émission avec un projet de loi qui est
passée aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres projet qui répond au doux nom
de climat et résilience il reprend un
certain nombre de propositions est à peu
près la moitié de des propositions
faites par la convention citoyenne sur
le climat assez classiquement les
écologistes purs se retrouvent quand ça
n'en fait pas assez
les industriels tous que ça va être
difficile bref on est dans le débat
traditionnel
écoutez ce que barbara pompili la
ministre la transition écologique die de
son projet il s'agit ni plus ni moins
d'arrêter le grand n'importe quoi
vaste programme cette loi en fait c'est
une loi qui va faire entrer l'écologie
est donc le bon sens dans la vie
quotidienne des français et les le bon
sens pourquoi ce que c'est deux choses
on va arrêter le grand n'importe quoi
sur un certain nombre de sujets et on va
aussi donner des solutions pratiques aux
français pour faire entrer l'écologie
alors il ya plein de mesures pratiques
dans ce dans ce projet il ya par exemple
la suppression des des vols pour les
destinations qui sont atteignables
à moins de dons en moins de 2h30 en
train ça fait cinq lignes aériennes
intérieures qui vont ainsi être
supprimés
il ya des aides pour rénover les
bâtiments il ya aussi la création d'un
crime déco side sur le fond
l'objectif de cette loi c'est de lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
mais comment est ce que vous trouvez que
c'est une bonne idée sachant que la
france elle est déjà l'un des meilleurs
élèves de la classe mondiale on est on
fait moins de 1%
alors est-ce qu'il faut montrer
l'exemple ou est ce que c'est que de la
com disons que de toute façon on sait
que collectivement au niveau mondial on
est en deçà de ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour atteindre les
les objectifs si on voulait éviter le
réchauffement climatique
donc de ce point de vue là il vaut
toujours mieux être le meilleur élève et
faire plus d'efforts que les autres
après si on se place dans un arbitrage
entre économie et environnement et où on
se dit que pour atteindre ses objectifs
on va nécessairement imposer des
contraintes un certain nombre de
contraintes aux entreprises en fait
battre ça veut dire quand même pénaliser
nos entreprises par rapport à d entre
eux afin à la concurrence à la
concurrence mondiale
donc c'est aussi un choix mais j'ai
l'impression que aujourd'hui être
européen
ça n'est pas juste défendre un modèle
économique mais c'est défendre un une
manière de vivre dont le respect de
l'environnement fait partie
et de ce point de vue là il me semble
que l'europe
en tout cas l'europe aurait du sens si
elle essayait de trouver une manière de
concilier performance économique et
respect de l'environnement
qu'ils soient en gros pas la manière
chinoise ou américaines pour faire
caricaturer le plus élevé que c'est une
bonne idée ce projet de loi ou c'est un
gadget selon vous alors moi je dis ça je
trouve que tout est dans le titre
il le climat résilience alors ce mot est
très à la mode dont là qu'on a comme
mode à toutes les sauces
l'armé qu'il était contre le coc vis de
telle opération résilience enfin c'est
un mode qui est sorti du vocabulaire de
boris cyrulnik et qui donc pardon comme
un cheveu sur la soupe on aurait pu
mettre d'autres mots ainsi un solitaire
c'est bien aussi enfin il ya un certain
nombre de mots qui montre que citoyen
citoyens en aurait pu dédire climat
durable solidaire citoyens résilience
aurait été beau voilà bon on a fait un
autre choix mais on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de communication
derrière ce qui est un peu frappant
c'est le décalage entre ce projet de loi
qui finalement
est assez déterré porte sur des
préoccupations assez lointaine c'est un
peu la politique des statistiques
c'est à dire que le matin les français
se lève pas en disant mon dieu comment
je vais terminer ma journée avec avec le
réchauffement cette affaire de
réchauffement climatique qui occupe mes
pensées alors que on sait bien qu'il ya
d'autres préoccupations beaucoup plus
pragmatique qui occupe l'esprit des
français
on parle sans arrêt de la cré de la
crise sanitaire il ya des aspects
sécuritaires et le chômage à l'aspect
économique
on voit bien que c'est c'est une
préoccupation qui est quand même assez
lointaine et de ce fait avec des
bénéfices aussi lointain parce que c'est
difficilement mesurable de savoir
l'impact corps à cette politique ça aura
un impact certes pratique pour un
certain nombre de français parce que ça
va les enquiquiner mais l'impact réel
sur le climat bien malin qui pourrait
qu'ils pourraient l'anticiper et puis
c'est un peu le le pays qui veut la
grenouille qui veut se faire plus grosse
que le boeuf c'est à dire que c'est la
tentation démiurge de porter le destin
du monde sur notre dos c'est très bien
que la france est un petit pays qui pèse
finalement assez assez faiblement sur le
lait les émissions etc
à comparer à d'autres mais l'idée qu'il
va l'aider qu'il faille montrer
l'exemple cesser ces belles valeurs là
aussi c'est beaucoup d'orgueil de la
part de la france parce que finalement
être un chef d'état qui montre l'exemple
être un état qui peut s'offrir le lusc
luxe de se préoccuper de ça parce qu'il
faut se rendre compte que l'écologie
encore une fois c'est une préoccupation
de 17 mai +1 quand on a rempli tous et
toutes les les besoins alimentaires etc
on peut se préoccuper de ces choses là
donc il ya beaucoup d'orgueil à vouloir
montrer l'exemple
est ce que la france en a encore les
moyens j'en doute fort surtout si cela
doit encore taper sur internet un
certain nombre de secteurs d'activité
comme je le disais vous êtes une
spécialiste de l'opinion publique est ce
qu'il n'ya pas
comme le laisse entendre gabris usa une
sorte de paradoxe dans la position des
français vis-à-vis de l'écologie ils
disent tous oui c'est important le
climat et pour cause puisque on leur
répète assez régulièrement et pour
autant on n'a pas le sentiment que soit
concrètement une priorité dans les dents
les dans les modes de consommation par
exemple du plus grand nombre
d'une certaine manière il existe un
gouffre entre la préoccupation affichée
par les français sur le clip de la
question climatique
contrairement aux états unis par exemple
on n'a pas de climato sceptiques ou très
peu donc l'immense majorité des français
considère que l'environnement c'est un
site un sujet et qu'il faut faire
quelque chose et qu'il faut plutôt faire
quelque chose très vite mais après nous
sommes un très grand nombre à avoir du
mal à traduire ça en actes et notamment
un acte de consommation et puis dans
notre vie quotidienne sur la manière
dont on se déplace la manière dont on
consomme et c'est un mets donc le enfin
bon moi j'ai tendance à penser que le
rôle des pouvoirs publics est plutôt de
facilité 7 7 ce passage à l'acte en fait
est de faciliter la vie de ceux qui
souhaiteraient être plus exemplaire en
quelque sorte pour préserver
l'environnement
parce que en réalité le raisonnement que
que vous venez de tenir c'est un
raisonnement qui est tenu par en fait
l'ensemble de la planète et l'ensemble
des gens c'est à dire effectivement moi
tout seul dans mon coin j'ai absolument
pas intérêt à m'embêter à faire
attention à la planète parce que c'est
pas moi qui vais changer quoi que ce
soit et on est dans un dilemme collectif
en fait d'actions collectives dont on
fête dont on peine à sortir on n'a aucun
instrument de gouvernance mondiale qui
soit suffisamment contraignant pour que
pour garantir que les uns et les autres
contribuent à leur juste part et que
donc on
on atteigne la taille critique en fait
d'actions qui permettrait d'avoir un
impact sur l'environnement et j'ai
l'impression que c'est un pas cela dans
laquelle nous sommes c'est à dire que
moi aujourd'hui je me disais je vais pas
ne pas faire d'efforts parce que les
autres n'en font pas et que moi tout
seul j'ai aucun impact et c'est ce que
se disent un trop grand nombre de gens
et pour l'instant on n'a pas trouvé la
solution aux commandes hier en termes de
gouvernance est lourd en terme de coût
accessoires personne ne trouve la
solution à cette impasse et donc on est
enfin c'est à mon avis c'est pour ça
qu'on continue à aller dans le mur en
fait sur le plan le plan du
réchauffement climatique dans cette loi
on ne parle pas de l'énergie nucléaire
alors même que c'est elle qui émet le
moins de gaz à effet de serre est ce que
à votre avis c'est normal car il accuse
l os qu'à une contradiction là dedans
sachant que le gouvernement a à assumer
la politique lancée par françois
hollande de diminution de la part du
nucléaire dans le mix énergétique avec
évidemment et c'était symbolique la
fermeture de fessenheim
oui c'est un peu le mistigri 1 le
nucléaire dans cette affaire parce que
c'est à la fois un emblème est un tabou
c'est à dire que pour l'électorat qui
est une qui représente une part
non-négligeable pour le gouvernement
moi je veux bien qu'ils aient un voeu
pieux qui est la volonté d'être beau et
gentil être donner l'exemple et d'être
merveilleux mais il ya aussi des
considérations électoralistes c'est
encore incertaine
c'est c'est évident donc parce que les
présidentielles approchent et que le
score de yannick jadot plane au dessus
des têtes et la présence de barbara
pompili n'est pas n'est pas seulement là
pour des considérations encore une fois
charitables non on sait bien que c'est
compliqué parce que les pour le
gouvernement c'est un totem le il est il
est écrit c'est gravé dans le marbre que
le nucléaire c'est pas bien et puis
voilà qu'on se rend compte que
finalement le bain c'est le fessenheim
peut-être que c'est ça et la déclaration
de barbara conflit
je crois que c'était il ya quelques
semaines qui a commencé à évoquer la
possibilité de deux pannes d'électricité
que de coupures d'électricité a plongé
tout le monde dans la stupéfaction
donc on se rend compte que finalement
fermer fessenheim ne s'était pas
forcément une bonne idée et puis
paradoxalement on se rend compte et vous
l'avez dit que les sur le plan écolo le
nucléaire c'est peut-être ce qui est
plus propre propre et on se rend compte
qu'en allemagne on rallume les usines à
charbon et on va peut-être être obligé
d'aller s'approvisionner chez les
allemands pour réussir à faire nos
affaires donc on voit bien que il ya
beaucoup ce qui est assez dangereux moi
je ne suis pas anti écologique mais
quand c'est de l'écologie concrètes
or on voit bien qu'il ya beaucoup de
d'incantations et de dogmes de foi qui
n'ont pas fait réellement leurs preuves
derrière les considérations écologiques
d'ailleurs il ya des objectifs qui sont
un peu lointain quoi des objectifs à
2028 2030
on a déjà connu ça avec ségolène royal
qui lorsqu'elle a fait des lois sur ces
sujets là nous a renvoyés effectivement
la sortie du nucléaire je crois en
l'occurrence à s'était déjà 2025-2030
2000 je sais pas combien
effectivement quand on enfin c'est bien
de donner des objectifs mais si on donne
pas le chemin concret pour pour y
parvenir c'est cesser purement
incantatoire
on est d'accord pour accueillir ce
discours aux français de dire écoutez le
nucléaire évidemment faut être très
prudent parce que ça peut être dangereux
mais n'empêche que la priorité c'est
climat et que donc c'est pas raisonnable
de fermer des centrales se serait
inaudible votre avis ah non je pense
qu'il ya disons que l'opinion est très
divisé sur cette question du nucléaire
et qui a une bonne part de l'opinion
qu'ils considèrent enfin qui est tout à
fait sensible à l'argument disant un cd
emploi de c'est finalement moins pire
que tout un tas d'autres solutions
tel que c'est lui justement le charbon
etc et donc l'impression que ça me donne
surtout c'est que c'est un sujet
extrêmement important et que le fait
qu'il soit évacué du débat ça donne le
sentiment que tous les sujets clivants
est un peu épineux ont été enlevés de la
loi et du débat est donc on a une loi ou
finalement oui je vois pas comment on
peut être vraiment contre cette loi
c'est à dire que globalement oui ça va
demander des efforts à telle ou telle
catégorie mais on n'est pas non plus
dans un truc différent
en revanche je crains que rien que
l'épidémie de kovy des davantage
d'impact sur nos modes de consommation
et nous rendre plus écolo que cette fois
là c'est ça ça reste quand même dans
l'ordre de l'anecdotique commentaires de
nos internautes
celui de babineau que nous allions sur
lefigaro.fr malgré toutes les tentatives
d' emmanuel macron de verdir son
quinquennat l'électorat vert n'est pas
convaincu on a vu lors des municipales
allusion sûrement aux bons scores
réalisés
voire même spectaculaire scores réalisés
par les écologistes en tout cas dans les
grandes métropoles
nicole 06 estime que nous sommes dans un
pays qui est certes pollueurs mais de
façon tellement faible par rapport aux
autres
et puis on vous a posé la question c'est
même la question du jour sur le figaro
êtes vous favorable à une autre
proposition que des manuels mâcon qui
est de
lancer un référendum pour inscrire la
préservation de l'environnement dans la
constitution et c'est non à 66%
ce référendum est grotesque estime
nicolau dick sur youtube ça ne servira à
rien et un autre internaute
mister last monday nous dit la charte de
l'environnement se trouve déjà dans le
bloc de constitutionnalité
inutile de modifier la constitution un
mot là-dessus gabriel crise est ce une
bonne idée au pas sur un référendum dans
les rendements bien que là aussi c'est
cette gadget il a dit qu'il ferait des
référendum alors il se dit que ce
sujet-là qui encore une fois est très
finalement assez lointain à ses intérêts
dont on ne peut pas en effet je trouve
que c'est vraiment pour moi cris salle
on ne peut pas monsieur on peut pas en
mesure et les résultats réellement il
peut faire toutes les politiques moi je
la juge très punitive cette politique
mais ensuite quelle voir les résultats
de cette politique ce sera extrêmement
difficile donc lancé un référendum
donner le sentiment qu'on demande l'avis
des uns des autres sur finalement un
sujet qui n'est pas au centre des
préoccupations concrètes et majeur de la
plupart des français quoi qu'on en dise
est bien ce ccc se faire sans doute une
main peu de popularité popularité à bon
compte parce que si on si je trouve
extrêmement important de rester sur
cette question là si on regarde tous les
sujets qui nous occupe la santé le
gouvernement peine à sortir de la crise
on va dire d'autres aussi et parle de
par le monde
certes mais il se trouve que c'est le
cas la sécurité le terrorisme l'économie
les retraites enfin on sent bien que si
on doit faire un bilan
tout cela est
et très très peu convaincant donc le
partir sur le registre de l'écologie
c'est typiquement le veut voeu pieux
qu'on ne pourra pas dont on ne pourra
pas évaluer finalement le bilan
et ça c'est tout ça t'a fait
satisfaisant c'est même très agréable
gouvernement bonne idée ce référendum
je pense que c'est enfin que l'immense
majorité des français pensent que c'est
une diversion que c'est un truc pour
faire comme si on allait les consulter
mais que finalement plus en plus en
france on a vraiment beaucoup plus
qu'ailleurs le sentiment que quand on
change un truc dans la loi scellier on a
agi on a changé la vie
et ça je pense que les gens n'en peuvent
plus donc je pense que c'est
effectivement que ça paraît une mesure
gadget qui ne va pas nécessairement
enfin amener les uns et les autres à
réévaluer son bilan et le pire c'est que
ça a l'air d'une prise de c'est une
fausse prise de risque c'est à dire que
effectivement comment comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait être contre once enfin
les gens sont au pire ils sont neutres
quoi mais personne ne va aller
et donc ça fait vraiment un fouet ces
infos référendum en fait bon et bien
voilà le pouvoir prévenu vous parliez à
l'instant d'abriel cluzel des enjeux de
sécurité
je propose de nous pencher sur une
initiative prise par le maire divers
droite de la ville de poissy en région
parisienne
karl olive
veut supprimer des allocations jeudi des
allocations parce que ce sont des avions
très ciblée divisez allocations
familiales d'ailleurs ce pas lui qui les
donne en l'occurrence c'est la caisse
d'allocations familiales mais par
exemple il veut pas supprimer les
tickets de cantine mais il souhaite
supprimer certaines allocations aux
mineurs délinquants de sa commune
il était ce matin l'invité de notre ami
yves thréard au toque du figaro et il
s'explique sur la philosophie de cette
mesure
gamin de 12 ans par exemple est pris en
flagrant délit pour incendies un sautoir
dans un stade avec un coût de
réparations à 20000 euros
est-ce que c'est au contribuable
pisciacais de payer et finalement de ne
rien pouvoir faire sur celui qui en a
fait le délit
ces suspensions suppression ces
suspensions dans un premier temps pour
créer cet électrochoc
et puis si jamais il ya récidive c'est
effectivement su preset autant un
message pour ces jeunes délinquants et
pour leurs familles sans aucune
stigmatisation
vous l'avez rappelé à juste titre
monsieur thréard il s'agit d' aides
facultatives certainement pas les aides
sociales
évidemment pour créer un électrochoc
pour les familles mais aussi un message
fort pour l'immense majorité de mes
administrés qui réclament simplement de
la justesse et gabriel usa une bonne
idée aussi d'un gadget pour reprendre un
terme employé dans la première partie de
cette émission c'est une bonne idée
c'est un serpent de mer aussi parce que
on sait que c'est un sujet qui revient
régulièrement sur le tapis c'est une
bonne idée mais en réalité ça ne va pas
très loin et et au delà de cette mesure
c'est toute une
une rhétorique est une façon de penser
qu'il faudrait sans doute changer et je
doute fort que lui tout seul avec ses
petits bras parviennent à le faire parce
qu'en réalité c'est tout là le comment
dire le traitement de la délinquance des
mineurs qu'il faudrait revoir alors ce
qui est positif qui est tout à fait
logique dans sa démarche c'est qui ce
dit on dit que les démineurs les mineurs
sont pas sont pas responsables donc il
ya bien un responsable sont les parents
nous sommes tous responsables de nous de
nos enfants donc ça aurait un caractère
dissuasif de suspendre ses allocations
minimales qui disons
son comme très marginal par rapport à la
somme des allocations les allocations
municipales n'existe pas dans toutes les
villes par exemple la france ce serait
supprimé les halles pour le sport pour
le sport les 60 euros pour les sports à
lomé comme ces jeunes gens font déjà du
sport en balançant d' encadrer boussou
ont poursuivi un polichinelle avec des
mortiers d'artifices bon bah ils le font
par ailleurs mais on sent dans son
intervention qu'il craint alors il dit
surtout ne touche pas aux autres
allocations de façon elles ne dépendent
pas de lui mais il craint de d'être jugé
comme pas gentil comme le l'oppresseur
des pauvres parce que il reste une
rhétorique de la délinquance dans ce
pays qui est figé dans le 19ème c'est à
dire que le la figure christique du
pauvre qui est délinquant parce qu'il
est pauvre et qu'il n'a pas le choix
donc c'est jean valjean qui va voler les
couverts en argent et l'évêque le est
gentil et lui redonne même les
chandeliers de ce fait jean valjean
devient extrêmement gentil c'est le
petit garçon qui vole un quignon de pain
est qui et qui
de deux parce qu'il n'a pas le choix et
qu'il doit manger
donc on est resté dans une vision très
romantique de la délinquance que ne
connaissent en fait que les bourgeois
entre guillemets je n'aime pas beaucoup
utilisé ce terme à l'âme enfin que ce
qui finalement ne sont pas au contact
des délinquants eux mêmes à la
délinquance actuellement c'est pas ça
c'est les trafics de drogue les bandes
les pour les petits mineurs c'est eux
qui qui chauffe enfin qui regarde dans
pendant les trafics parce que on sait
qu'il n'y aura pas de conséquences
judiciaires c'est un sentiment
d'impunité et et c'est le sentiment de
l'argent facile donc c'est pas en
donnant de l'argent que l'on rendra
nécessairement moins délinquants et on a
du mal à sortir de cette rhétorique on
le voit même avec son intervention il
veut faire ça parce qu il le dit
lui-même s'appelait à mes administrés
mais il précise tout de suite nous
n'irons pas au delà parce que encore une
fois ce serait atteindre aux pauvres
entre les mets et donc je veux
exactement ce stigmate is est donc en
fait c'est tout un paradigme tout une
appréhension de la délinquance qui est
simplement une appréhension de la
réalité de la délinquance dans sa
réalité qu'il faudrait changer mais je
crains qu'il ne puisse pas le faire seul
un autre point de vue sur cette mesure
que c'est assez anecdotique
effectivement sur ce que ça touche en
termes d' aide comme comme vous venez de
le dire la difficulté dans cette dans
cette affaire c'est que si vous voulez
moi je suis pour la responsabilité mais
la question c'est comment est-ce qu'on
responsabilise vraiment les gens est-ce
que c'est efficace de faire ça même en
allant plus loin c'est à dire on a connu
la suppression des allocations
familiales pour les jeunes absents
absentéistes etc etc
j'ai plutôt l'impression que même
lorsqu'on dit bon il faut quand même que
qui est un cadre et qui est une autorité
qui est une responsabilité c'est
absolument anormal de laisser enfin de
laisser des gosses faire n'importe quoi
et ce n'est pas normal que leur pas
leurs parents ne les encadrent pas bon
une fois qu'on a dit ça
comment on fait c'est à dire que
généralement par exemple les parents de
ces gamins sont déjà dépassés donc
est-ce que c'est en leur supprimant des
aides à eux que ça va les aider
peut-être que c'est conforme à une
notion de justice ou que ça nous fera
plaisir parce qu'on les aura à humilier
on les aura punis mais est-ce que ça va
être efficace
j'ai l'impression que les
expérimentations qui ont été faites et
pas qu ici dans tous les pays c'est
plutôt que non en fait ça aggrave le
problème donc un bon on n'a pu ni la
famille du délinquant mais mais mais on
n'a pas résolu le problème donc ma
question c'est vraiment ça c'est ok très
bien on veut responsabiliser les gens
mais comment on fait est là dessus vous
l'avez dit à l'instant c'est un serpent
de mer parce que justement on n'a pas
vraiment trouvé la solution pour être à
la fois dans un dans une solution qui
soit responsabilisante et qui permette y
compris la réparation parce que moi je
pense que quand même quand on est un
enfant
enfin quand on est un mineur on est
encore en apprentissage et donc on doit
pouvoir quand même revenir dans le droit
chemin et il faut pas abandonner cette
dimension là donc comment est ce qu'on
fait en sorte qu'ils aient réparation et
que les choses soient elles soit
efficace quoique on se penche se fasse
pas plaisir à faire des mesures justes
pour faire des mesures
mais qui n'ont aucune efficacité nos
internautes sont plutôt favorables à
cette initiative du maire de poissy on
vous pose la question sur twitter la
suspension voire la suppression de
certaines allocations pour les familles
de délinquants devrait-elle être
pratiquée partout en france comme à
poissy et la réponse est oui à 75%
il faut responsabiliser les parents au
lieu de victimiser leurs enfants sans
arrêt nous dit jean luc pirard sur
youtube élan sur lefigaro.fr sur
lefigaro.fr pardon évidemment qu'il ne
faut pas payer un centime pour les
familles qui nous pose problème puisse
être réflexion de marie kiki c'est sans
doute un pseudonyme sur lefigaro.fr
toujours et les travaux d'intérêt
général pour ces ados perdu leur faire
prendre conscience de leurs devoirs
vis-à-vis de la société point
d'interrogation
cette idée de réparations ça vous paraît
une une bonne une bonne piste gabriel
péri je voulais revenir c'est que nous
on est un peu dans un état
il y règne un livre du reste qui
s'appelait comme sa big mother c'est à
dire que l état serait comme une bonne
mère de famille comme mère teresa qui
serait là pour amener de la porte et
finalement dû du soin et et la
compassion alors c'est un peu cynique ce
que je vais dire mais les allocations
familiales à titre collectif ne sont
sont là pour permettre sont pas là pour
ça elles sont là pour permettre aux gens
des levées
correctement leurs enfants de façon à
favoriser la paix sociale un climat
social propice à la vie sereine de
chacun donc elle n'est là ni finalement
pour faire l'éducation individuel si
vous voulez ça c'est de ce sens être la
famille qui le fait donc dans la
réparation oui pourquoi pas mais
l'éducation elle est quand même en
premier au premier chef du ressort de la
famille et elle n'est pas là non plus
pour pour encore une fois faire du soin
on le à la place d'une oeuvre caritative
donc quand on donne les allocations
familiales s'il ya une sorte
d'investissement sur un plan économique
on espère un retour sur investissement
c'est à dire que une bonne éducation
c'est pour permettre à la famille
d'éduquer correctement l'enfant donc si
c'est un peu ce que développe
l'économiste jacques bichot si vous avez
déjà vu un peu ce qu'il écrit notamment
sur les retraites les allocations
familiales
donc si il n'y a pas ce retour sur
investissement si la famille en retour
n'éduque pas correctement l'enfant eh
bien il est assez légitime qu'on
suspende ses allocations parce que ce
ces allocations ne trouve pas à
s'employer comme elle devrait
alors oui des réparations pourquoi pas
les quel est ce qu elles seront
effectuées pourquoi c'est un serpent de
mer aussi sans doute parce qu'en réalité
elles sont très peu appliquées
ce sont des signaux à l'endroit des
électeurs à un moment donné vous avez
parlé de la loi d'eric ciotti
je pense que c'est à ça que je faisais
allusion 2010 sur laquelle françois
hollande est revenu rappelle qu' elle
prévoyait alors c'est pour l'absentéisme
scolaire voilà sur certaines allocations
en cas d'absentéisme scolaire répété
chez les enfants mais en réalité elle l
a trouvée très peu à s'employer il faut
vérifier l'absentéisme des professeurs
sont aussi dans une optique de il faut
pas stigmatiser les quelles sanctions
comment vérifier enfin et c'est là donc
c'est vrai que est dans les faits
elle a été peu peut appliquer c'est pour
ça que c'est difficile de vérifier sa
son efficacité alors on parler
d'efficacité mais est ce que tu appelles
avoir aussi dimension symbolique dans ce
genre de mesure chloé morin c'est à dire
de dire bah bah c'est c'est une façon à
défaut de régler le problème de dire aux
citoyens mais vous voyez on essaie de
faire ce qu'on peut même si c'est pas
très efficace si moi je pense que c'est
important d'un vote d'envoyer des
signaux et de montrer que quelque part
les règles de manière générale sont
respectées si elles sont perçues comme
juste et donc que si on est dans un
système où on se dit que finalement on
est toujours les mêmes et que ceux qui
ceux qui rament et qui respecte les
règles
ils sont laissons jamais aidé ça peut
pas marcher mais il faut quand même
qu'ils aient un équilibre entre eux
l'importance des symboles et puis
l'efficacité
peut-être que au lieu d'aller supprimer
des aides qui a l'air pas très efficace
il faut miser sur un encadrement de ces
jeunes là je sais que c'est pas c'est
parce qu'on fait on les retire pas de
leur famille mais à un moment donné si
les parents sont complètement défaillant
et qu'il faut et qu'il faut les éduquer
en dehors on peut bien on peut très bien
envisager ça et ça c'est pas du manque
de fermeté au contraire mais en termes
d'efficacité
je pense qu'on a on a de toute façon on
n'a pas la culture en france de
l'évaluation de ce qu'on fait donc on
voit des trucs y compris des trucs qui
coûte très cher et on évalue jamais s'il
ya eu un retour justement sur
investissement ça vaudrait le coup de
d'expérimenter un certain nombre de
choses et de se dire bon ben voilà
qu'est ce qui est le plus efficace pour
lutter contre la délinquance des mineurs
et puis après 2 en plus c'est ce qui
serait bien c'est que ça donnerait ça
mettrait tout le monde d'accord autour
de la table c'est à dire qu on
arrêterait de s'épuiser en débat
idéologique qui sont qu'ils sont
au final au final assez épuisant mais
les ministres parfois et va le plus les
retombées médiatiques de leur initiative
que leur efficacité sur le moyen terme
peut-être déjà été été éprouvée on a
tout essayé un bon on a été beaucoup de
choses d'encadrement militaire citoyens
comme on disait tout à l'heure on a les
centres de jeunes justement on en parle
régulièrement ça aussi c'est un serpent
de mer
en réalité il faut être tout à fait
clair on est face à un problème qui est
extrêmement qui dépasse beaucoup de
politiques qui qui plonge les français
dans dans dans une halle à la
stupéfaction qui s'est un peu comme la
délinquance d'ensauvagement de notre
société c'est un peu comme les
l'islamisme
on a l'impression qu'il ya une montée
inexorable et puis les élus sur le
terrain se disent il faut que j'envoie
quelques signaux faut que j'envoie
quelques signaux donc je vais envoyer
signal là ça va faire plaisir c'est vrai
que bon ça ça paraît logique est ce que
in fine et ça va résoudre le problème
c'est sans doute essayer de vider
l'océan ou des avec un dé à coudre le
tout seul le maire va avoir du mal à
faire à faire quoi que ce soit mais au
moins ça ça envoie ce signal à ses
administrés qui ne le king qui voit le
problème répond dire et puis je vous
fait part de cette dernière réaction
celle de jeu petit 74 et sur lefigaro.fr
qui considère lui que avec cette
délinquance des mineurs on paye surtout
la lâcheté de l'éducation nationale avec
des réformes qui n'était pas souhaitée
par les enseignants merci beaucoup à
tous les deux d'avoir été sur le plateau
de point de vue merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis et bien sûr on aura de la
joie de se retrouver demain sur le
figaro live merci
[Musique]